it's interesting man I definitely could
say that over my life I remember the
first cell phone bill ever got it was
like $7,000 right I didn't realize you
couldn't just use your phones once you
want it I thought I got this [ __ ] man I
had a hundred minutes okay like a hunter
Menace when cell phones came out it was
just enough minutes to really realize
you don't you you cannot afford a cell
phone man every call you had to be like
hey it was almost like you were in that
movie where you have like there's like a
timer and it's gonna blow up or
something so it was like every call that
came in oh you'd have to try and get it
you remember that used to like I've read
it about 50 seconds you'd be looking
back all right man we get a my first
cell phone plan I was late to the game
because I had to pay for my own cell
phone in high school was was unlimited
they had already moved into those types
of tight plans it was it was a benefit
of waiting but yeah I mean my grandma
was always worried about her minutes man
she would nights and weekends that
that's what I do week is boy live like
look man I can't call you know after
9:00 a.m. so if you had a friend that
was in any other timezone as a kid you
was [ __ ] he was not friends anymore
did you before cell phones play the
Colet call game I would I would have to
collect call to go get picked up and yes
I'd be at the Y and be Ike it's Nick I'm
done and my grandma would come and pick
me up 15 minutes later yeah man that was
awesome that was always a good move and
the movie theater game like they had to
click over so how if I was gonna have a
probably gonna have a girl call me back
late at night I would say okay you know
at about 9:20 i'ma call a movie theater
line because they had like a 40-minute
message on there and it was like now
showing this weekend at 7 The Bodyguard
starring Whitney Houston and Kevin
Costner show times are Monday through
Friday 5:00 p.m. and 7:00 p.m. Saturday
matinee 2 p.m. and 4:30 p.m. Saturday
and Sunday evening 5 7 & 9 p.m. then it
would be like now showing in a theater
too and then it would go into the next
movie you know Land Before Time
Wow this young dinosaur doesn't know
what's going to occur starring the
voices of you know Lou Diamond Phillips
and then we just keep going so we're
like a 40-minute message so if you had
that call waiting then you could hear
someone calling you the beep and it
wouldn't ring in your house - yeah so be
like alright I'm gonna call the movie
theater and hope she called now
sometimes your girl would fall asleep
you know because [ __ ] be rest and
everybody knows that though if you go
looking at 9:00 [ __ ] probably about
two of them resting so then you just
heard the entire movie three or four
times and then in my dreams at night it
was just the background loop it was just
just me and popcorn you know mm-hmm
what was this question what was this
about he was just kind of reiterating
your sentiment about the student loans
just yeah keep dragging it out yeah keep
dragging it out that's a good but also
yeah the the thing we forget so though
sometimes it yeah we made a deal you
know we did make a deal I mean big
companies do get kind of fight everybody
just thinks they can [ __ ] them mm-hmm
but they also [ __ ] people every chance
they get probably goes unnoticed but
that doesn't mean we have to act like
that right right yeah minutes it's a
real battle god I remember oh I remember
I'd send letters to Verizon like man
[ __ ] y'all bruh you know I remember
sending pictures of me from photographs
of me with like this with my hands in
the air holding my pockets out like I
have no money
I would $7,000 dude so and somebody oh I
remember this was the worst somebody
kept calling me from Africa bruh
and I don't know how they got my number
I don't know how Africa even got a phone
at this point like I didn't know they
had even had a phone in Africa but they
kept calling me and I would get charged
when I answered it you know did you guys
talk huh did you guys talk yeah
sometimes but it was so hard to know
what's going on bro Africa I mean Africa
is pretty wild and imagine Africa on the
phone maybe it was that Gollum saying if
Africa cauldre I'm not saying don't
answer brother you know maybe you know
just maybe don't answer every time
executive in good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one